>> From The Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Janice Hyde: Good morning.
Welcome to the John W. Kluge
Center at The Library of Congress.
My name is Janice Hyde, and
I am privileged to serve
as the Interim Director
of the Kluge Center.
Before we begin today's
program, please take a moment
to silence your cell phones
and other electronic devices.
I see everybody reaching, thank you.
I'll also make you aware that
today's program is being filmed
for placement on the
Kluge Center website,
as well as its YouTube
and iTunes channels.
We are also live tweeting this
event, so if you would like to tweet
or re-tweet or just join the
Twitter conversation please do
so using hashtag life emerges.
The John W. Kluge Center is
pleased to host today's symposium,
The Emergence of Life on the
Earth, in the Lab and Elsewhere,
which has been organized and will
be led by Dr. Nathaniel Comfort,
who is the Blumberg NASA/Library
of Congress Chair in Astrobiology.
The Kluge Center is a vibrant
Center for scholarly research
on Capitol Hill that brings together
individuals from around the world
to exchange ideas and learn from
one another, to distill wisdom
from the Library's rich
resources and to interact
with policymakers and the public.
The Center offers opportunities
for senior scholars
and postdoctoral fellows
to do research using the
unparalleled collections
of The Library of Congress.
It offers free public
lectures, conferences, symposia
and other programs and it
administers the Kluge Prize,
which recognizes outstanding
lifetime achievement
in the humanities and
social sciences.
To view past programs
or to learn more
about the Kluge Center please
visit our website at loc.gov/kluge.
The Blumberg Chair in
Astrobiology is a result
of what has been a unique and
rewarding collaboration between NASA
and The Library of Congress.
It takes its name from Nobel Prize
Winner Baruch Barry, Blumberg,
Founder of the NASA Astrobiology
Institute and a Founding Member
of The Library of Congress
Scholars Council.
Dr. Blumberg envisioned the creation
of a Chair in the Kluge Center
that would focus on the humanistic
and societal impacts
of astrobiology.
Nathaniel Comfort is the third
person to hold the Blumberg Chair,
and I'm delighted to say that
the two previous Chair holders,
David Grinspoon and Steven Dick,
as well as the incoming Chair,
Luis Campos, are all with us today.
And please note that we are
currently accepting applications
for the 2017-2018 Chair.
As I hope any of the past Chairs
will tell you this is a fantastic
opportunity to spend a year
of research, reflection
and writing at the Kluge Center.
The application is
available on our website
and the submission
deadline is December 1st,
so please consider applying yourself
or encouraging others to do so.
It has been a true pleasure
to have Nathaniel with us
at the Kluge Center this year.
He spent his time examining the
history of the genomic revolution
and origin of life research.
Dr. Comfort is a Professor in
the Department of the History
of Medicine at Johns
Hopkins University.
He has published several
books and scores of articles,
including his book, The
Science of Human Perfection,
How Genes Became the Heart
of American Medicine.
He has written for The
Atlantic, The Nation,
The New York Times Book
Review, among others.
His blog is
Genotopia.scienceblog.com
and he tweets from @nccomfort.
Before Nathaniel takes the stage
to launch today's program I would
like to invite Dr. Mary Voytek, the
Senior Scientist for Astrobiology
at NASA, to the podium to give
some introductory remarks.
Dr. Voytek?
>> Mary Voytek: Well, thank you very
much for allowing me to do this,
and I'm delighted that this is the
third or fourth time I've been able
to be up on this podium and
I hope we continue it along
into the rest of the
decade at least.
The Kluge Center agreement
that we have
with NASA has been
extremely important
to explore an area that's
fundamental to NASA's mission,
which is looking at the
societal implications
of the work that we do at NASA.
The search for life has been
part of our original mission
and a responsibility to the
public has always been a part
of our mission, both
to inform and educate,
to let you know what we're doing,
and also to establish studies
to look at the consequences
and benefits of the exploration
that we're doing in space.
And one of the things
that we have typically
or we generally focus
on are enabling science.
So I run a research program that
actually funds research projects
to understand the origins and
evolution of life here on earth
in order to characterize the
sort of habitats we might look
for life elsewhere in the
solar system and beyond.
But one of the areas that we have
not made a substantial impact
on is really evaluating
the societal impacts.
And the Kluge Center and this Chair
has served a very important role
in allowing us to bring in scholars
from the humanities, philosophy,
theology, history, many other
scholars besides scientists
to interact with scientists
to actually explore these
very important issues.
So I should have probably begun
by saying what can you imagine being
more exciting than our discovery
of life somewhere else
in our universe?
And I think that this last half
decade or so has been remarkable
in encouraging us and informing
us on what that search should look
like in looking for it and
the possibility of finding it.
I just highlight that
it's two years ago
that we discovered
the first XO-planet.
We suspected that there were planets
that were orbiting other stars,
but we actually confirmed it.
And then since then we've
actually discovered thousands
of planets orbiting stars and
at least a couple dozen that are
in what are the so-called
habitable zone, that's the distance
from a star that allows a planet
to actually have a hospitable
environment on its surface
that could potentially
support life as we know it.
And now when you look up into the
sky you're not looking at stars,
but you're looking at suns
and around each and every one
of those suns we imagine
are planets.
So the billions and billions and
billions of stars are now billions
and bazillions of planets and that
has to be incredibly exciting,
that you yourself can observe.
We've spent the last several decades
exploring the habitability on Mars
and we're learning more and more.
You know, our mantra has
always been look for the water
and we're finding water everywhere.
And our most recent launch last
week, we launched OSIRIS-Rex,
which is a mission that's going out
to take a sample from an asteroid.
And one of the things that
we believe about those bodies
in our solar system is they are
responsible for delivering water
and organics, two essential
things for life, to our planets
and delivering it to other
places around our solar system
that might create habitable
environments.
In addition, we've started looking
at extending what we used to think
of as a habitable zone, where
earth is in the sweet spot,
but looking at places like
the moons that orbit Saturn,
the giant planets, gas
planets, Saturn and Jupiter,
and looking at the
so-called ocean worlds.
And we're pleased to see that
this has caught the imagination
of our policymakers and
lawmakers and now we have funding.
In fact, we just got - we
usually get unfunded mandates,
so if somebody decides
we need to do something
and we don't typically
get money, and this year,
past year we got a
funded non-mandate,
that basically said we think
ocean worlds is really important
for exploration at NASA and we
want you to go set something up.
And it wasn't, you know, we didn't
have a lot of strings attached
and it allowed us to really
explore what might be needed
to really move forward.
And the moons that I'm talking
about are in Enceladus and Europa,
and so I'm sure you've
heard a lot about this.
Enceladus, in particular,
is a moon of Saturn
that has been spewing its interior
ocean, which we believe Europa has
as well, out into space and so
we want to have the opportunity
to explore these new planets
or new planetary bodies
that could support life.
I would also just say, my
last comment, as you may know
that very recently, I think it
was within the last two weeks,
maybe last week, losing
track of time,
it's the end of the fiscal year,
kind of crazy at a government
agency, but there was a report
that scientists had found
evidence of life here on earth
at 3.7 billion years ago.
That means that it took much less
time than we may have thought before
for life to start from nothing,
just the building blocks,
and to have it have arisen to the
point where there's enough of it
around that we were able
to detect it somewhere.
And that's a phenomenal discovery,
so now we have all these planets
orbiting stars, we have planets
that seem to be in the right
space that could support life,
and now we know that
it's maybe not as hard
as we thought for life to occur.
So we at NASA and the Astrobiology
Program think it's highly likely
that we're going to find
life somewhere else.
And when we do we need to know what
all of the public thinks about it
and this seminar is going to
address some of those things.
So thank you very much.
Thank you so much, Nathaniel.
This is a great lineup, and
thank you all for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Okay, well,
thank you very much,
Mary, for those remarks.
And I just want to say that if we
do find life elsewhere it's going
to be a very long time before
it evolves into something
as cool as the Kluge Center.
I have had an absolutely
marvelous time this year.
I've gotten to do all sorts of - I
had all sorts of great adventures,
not least including getting to
go bowling with Astrobiologists
at the White House,
which was really awesome.
Mary, I think, got a strike, I got a
couple strikes, it was really cool.
And I've been poking around the
thermal pools at Yellowstone.
I've gotten out to the
Jet Propulsion Laboratory
and made chemical gardens.
The access - the Library is
an obvious and incredible set
of resources, but NASA also
provides an amazing set
of resources that we can draw upon.
And getting to have both of those
and try to pull that together
into something meaningful
has been a tremendous treat.
So I just wanted to give
you a very brief sort
of conceptual overview
of the conference.
I'm not going to take long
before we can turn it over
and begin the actual sessions.
But I wanted to tell
you a little bit.
Well, first of all, let me
just thank everybody here
at the Kluge Center for their --
this is an amazing team
of incredibly professional
and friendly and warm people.
Jason Steinhauer, Dan Turello,
and especially JoAnne Kitching,
the Administrator here, who
keeps everything together,
and John [inaudible] does an
incredible job with the AV.
So thank you to everybody.
Oh, and not to forget
Emily, also a very,
very important member of the team.
So thank you.
Okay, so my project is, Mary said,
has been to examine the history,
the recent history of
origin of life research.
In the last 35 or 40 years the
way scientists have thought
about the origin of life
has changed dramatically.
It is, historians shy away from
the word scientific revolution,
it's become kind of a cliche,
but it's a scientific revolution.
The old, what you learned about
the primordial soup and all
that stuff is gone, the
soup is out the window,
and there are whole new ways of
thinking about how life emerges
and it's a tremendously
exciting period.
And so I've been trying to
piece some of that together,
and so that's been my project.
And what I wanted to do today was
to bring together groups of people
who are working on different
aspects of that problem.
And one of my favorite things to
do is to get people who rarely talk
to each other in a serious way,
together talking in a serious way.
So I have invited historians,
philosophers, scientists
and science writers to bring their
expertise to bear on questions
of the search for life, the origins
of life on earth and in the lab,
which means synthetic biology,
efforts to create life in the lab
and a lot of overlap with
the search for or the study
of the possible mechanisms of
the origins of life on earth.
Some people, such as Steve
Bennett [Assumed Spelling],
have actually worked
in both of those areas.
And then, of course, all of
that bears upon the search
for the possibility of life as
we know it on other planets.
So these are all very
much integrated dimensions
of astrobiology.
And I am absolutely thrilled to have
such a great group of experts here.
These are some of the absolute
top people in their areas,
and you all should
feel very privileged
to get a chance to
meet all these folks.
And I encourage you at coffee
break to try to engage them.
They're also all very
nice warm people.
So, with that, I think we're going
to turn it over to Nsikan Akpan,
who is with the PBS New Hour,
Senior Science Producer, is that -
with them, and he is going to
be moderating the first session.
What I've done is asked some of
the best science writers I know
to moderate these sessions.
What they're great at is
interpreting science and scholarship
in ways that the regular people
can understand and really good
at interviewing people and
pulling out the important themes.
So I've asked them to do
that, and they're going
to be leading some
discussion with the panelists
and fielding questions
with the audience, okay?
So, with that, Nsikan?
>> Nsikan Akpan: Hello, everyone.
I just want to start by
thanking The Library of Congress,
NASA and the Kluge
Center for inviting me
to moderate what I think is going
to be a very fascinating panel.
The title of that panel is The
Emergence of Life on Earth,
and we have one programming note
in that Jim Cleaves couldn't make
it today due to a personal matter.
So our first speaker
is actually going
to be our last speaker, Nathaniel.
Nathaniel, as you heard, is
the Blumberg/NASA Library
of Congress Chair in Astrobiology
here at the Kluge Center.
He's also a Professor
of History and Medicine
at the Johns Hopkins University.
And his current research
focuses on the origin of life
and his talk today is going
to focus on the creation
of the early genetic code.
Our other speaker is Matt Schrenk.
He's Assistant Professor
in the Departments of Earth
and Environmental Sciences and
Microbiology and Molecular Genetics
at Michigan State University.
His research studies
microbial activities
in hydrothermal environments
in the deep sea and deep earth.
And his recent publications have
focused on genomics based methods
to study the function and evolution
of these microbes in order to sort
of glean a picture of what early
microbes might have looked like.
So, with no further ado, Nathaniel?
>> Nathaniel Comfort: All
right, first, let me just say
that this is very much a work in
progress because this is stuff
that I've been doing
all this past year.
So some of the data for
this talk has actually come
in this week, so please
bear with me.
A lot of this is new,
I've been really trying
to integrate a lot of new material.
But if you can bear with me, and
it gets a little geeky at times,
I admit, but if you
bear with me I'm going
to give you all you need to know.
You don't have to be a technical
scientist to understand this,
and if you do you'll have a
better appreciation I think
of how science works
and why we think
about the origins of
life the way we do.
I open with one of my
favorite illustrations
by M.C. Escher, Three Worlds.
In one sense this is all
one world, of course, right?
Yet the tree and the carp
are unaware of each other.
The pond surface, the
interface between the two,
reflects one and reveals the other.
In the world of the
picture it constructs both.
Well, I want to do something
similar to that with one
of the central concepts in origin
of life research, the RNA world.
The usual explanation of what
the RNA world is goes something
like this.
There's a chicken-and-egg problem
at the heart of modern biology.
Most of the genes spelled out in
our DNA encode the instructions
for making proteins.
Among the most important proteins
are enzymes, complex molecules
that catalyze biological reactions.
Among the reactions that enzymes
catalyze are the synthesis of DNA.
In other words, you can't
make proteins without genes
and you can't make
genes without proteins.
How did this system evolve?
The RNA world breaks
this infinite loop.
Differing from DNA by only one atom
it's capable of storing information,
just like DNA, but it's
usually single stranded,
which means it's more
chemically reactive than DNA.
In fact, in the 1980s researchers
found that RNA can act as an enzyme.
It can then in theory copy itself,
perhaps it also evolved
a way to make proteins.
So proof there goes the
chicken-and-egg problem
and a bird-like dinosaur
gave rise to both, all right?
That's the RNA world.
So the RNA world then
describes a time very early
in evolution before DNA, before
protein, when RNA did both jobs.
Eventually it handed off information
storage to DNA, which is more stable
and can copy itself very easily,
and it handed off most catalysis
to proteins, which are more
complex and versatile and,
therefore, more powerful.
The canonical history of the
RNA world is very simple.
In the 1960s the researchers
first speculated
on the idea of RNA catalysis.
The first person always mentioned
is Francis Crick of Watson and Crick
and the double helix, and often
usually mentioned is his colleague,
Leslie Orgel.
Sometimes the renegade
Microbiologist,
Carl Woese, is also mentioned.
Then people say there was a
period in which not much was done
with this idea because it was just
a speculation and no one knew what
to do with it until in the early
'80s RNA catalysis was actually
found twice by Tom Cech's group
at Colorado and then independently
by Sidney Altman's [Assumed
Spelling] group at Yale.
And then shortly thereafter
the RNA world was articulated
by Walter Gilbert in 1986.
And that's sort of it.
Well, surprise, surprise, I've found
that there's a lot
more to it than that.
There is a rich context and
an earlier history going back
to the early 1950s that I
can only weigh that today.
I'm going to spend most of my
time cutting into this period
in which supposedly nothing
happened and I'm going to close
with a few remarks on how this
narrative of the RNA world
that people understand was carved
out of all of this other stuff
that I'm going to be talking about.
My hope is to give you at least a
taste of what was really at stake
in the creation of the RNA world.
So here briefly are the remarks
that earned the early guys' credit
for predicting the RNA world.
In his 1967 book, The
Genetic Code, Carl Woese wrote
of the era of nucleic acid life.
This was based on a speculative
and later disproven idea
about the function of the
molecule transfer RNA,
and in this Woese concluded
that a proto RNA could have
been the original genome.
Then the next year
Francis Crick imagined
that the primitive protein synthesis
machinery could have been made
entirely of RNA.
In a companion paper in the same
journal his colleague, Leslie Orgel,
said that a primordial protein
only world was impossible
because of the nature of
proteins they're not able
to template their own replication
and a nucleic acid only
world was possible,
but he said it wouldn't
have gotten very far,
it wouldn't have gotten past
what he called the stage
of evolutionary doodling until
it had evolved a genetic code
to link nucleic acids
and proteins, okay?
So my main point here is simply that
because the early RNA world evolved
around the genetic code
and its origin it presumed
the existence of protein.
That's not true for
the later RNA world.
So thinking about the genetic
code implies an RNA protein world.
Because today is - oh, and
here's the RNA protein world,
this is the genetic code.
And so even from these
brief snippets it's obvious
that all these three were
writing in the context
of making proteins, right?
The genetic code and
the nucleotide sequence
of the transfer RNA had just been
solved in the preceding years,
in the 1960s, crowning
touches on a decade's worth
of spectacular research
characterizing the machinery
involved in reading out
the nucleic acid sequence
and converting it into proteins.
And the whole complicated
process was shot through with RNA.
We had messenger RNA,
transfer RNA, ribosomal RNA.
And so molecular biologists saw
the flow of genetic information
through the cell as one of
the defining essences of life
and this essence was
mediated by RNA.
Even though they weren't trained
in evolutionary biology they
immediately recognized the question
of how something is
abstract and self-referential
as the genetic code could
have evolved and that
that was a knotty and
important problem.
So this is the RNA protein world.
Now because my focus today is
mainly on Walter Gilbert I'm going
to jump forward a few years to 1976.
That year Gilbert and
his student, Allan Maxam,
invented a new technique
for sequencing DNA.
The paper describing the method
was published in February of 1977.
This followed the method invented
by Frederick Sanger in 1975,
but Maxam-Gilbert sequencing
was a good deal faster
and it became the method of
choice for sequencing DNA
until automated DNA
sequencing came in in the 1990s,
which sort of sent us hurtling
toward the human genome project.
Gilbert had trained as a
physicist, but had been immersed
in the RNA world since
the mid-1950s.
He had participated in the
discovery of messenger RNA in 1960
and he shared the laboratory
of Jim Watson, the other half
of Watson and Crick at Harvard.
And in 1976 Watson moved
down to Long Island
to become fulltime Director of
Cold Spring Harbor Laboratory
and bequeathed his
entire lab to Gilbert,
and Gilbert did some pretty
interesting things there.
So in the spring of 1977 the
immunologist, Susumu Tonegawa,
visited Gilbert's lab and in order
to sequence some of the genes
that he was finding for
immunoglobulins, important molecules
that create the antigens
that recognize the antibodies
in our immune system, okay?
And Gilbert says when
he says Tonegawa came
to sequence it he meant
that Maxam sequenced it.
And Maxam found when he was doing
this, found this 93 base sequence
that appeared to be skipped
over during transcription.
So the messenger RNA from the
gene was missing this chunk
of DNA, right?
And they didn't quite
know what to do with that,
but that June they went down to
Long Island to the Annual Symposium
at Cold Spring Harbor
Lab where they heard
about a stunning new
development in gene structure
in higher organisms or eukaryotes.
Independently Richard Roberts, a
scientist at Cold Spring Harbor,
and Phil Sharp, who had been at
Cold Spring Harbor but was now
by this time at MIT, performed
essentially the same experiment.
They captured the messenger RNA from
a viral gene and then hybridized it
to the original DNA gene, and
when they did so and looked at it
under the electron microscope
they found these loops, okay?
So the messenger RNA, you can
see, is binding to the DNA
and it's skipping over
chunks of the DNA.
In other words, the DNA
gene existed in segments
with little spacers
in between them, okay?
This was one of the many discoveries
in science that made anomalies
in other researchers'
data suddenly make sense.
Rich Roberts told me back in
1993 they all had the data
in their notebooks, all they had to
do was go back and reinterpret it.
Gilbert went back and
reinterpreted it.
So after the symposium
he took a trip to Europe.
Gilbert likes to travel the
world, and he went to Switzerland
to visit Tonegawa, he went to
Poland to visit another scientist.
And as he was traveling around
he said he had a big idea.
The genes weren't in pieces,
he thought, they weren't just
in pieces, he thought,
they must be modular.
He imagined that the coding regions
represented ancient mini genes
that would have functioned on
their own and he was already
by this time calling the
intervening sequences introns
and the coding regions exons, okay?
And the evolutionary role
of introns, he thought,
was to enable the exons
to be shuffled in order
to rapidly create complex genes.
When I came back to Harvard for
the fall term, Gilbert told me,
I was very excited about the
exon shuffling idea and gave it
as a seminar, centering
on the idea that genes
and pieces might explain
the Cambrian evolution,
Cambrian explosion.
The evolutionary burst around 540
million years ago in which most
of the major animal phyla appeared.
Introns had not been seen in
bacteria, they'd only been seen
in eukaryotes, higher organisms.
So if, as many people believed,
simple prokaryotes, like bacteria,
had evolved into complex
eukaryotes then Gilbert thought the
introduction of introns could
have sped the diversification
of higher organisms leading
to the Cambrian explosion.
Now note that this reasoning is
based on a lot of assumptions
that are no longer believed
as to be true, okay?
But this is the way he was thinking
and it was reasonable
thinking at the time.
So Ford Doolittle began a
sabbatical year in Gilbert's lab
that same fall, when Gilbert
came back all excited.
And he remembers Gilbert's
seminar and he told me
that afterward he went
home that night
and wrote an essay in response.
Doolittle had trained
under Carl Woese,
who was at this time campaigning
heavily to get rid of this idea
of a prokaryote to eukaryote
progression in evolution.
And Doolittle was kind infected
with that idea, why should we think
that prokaryotes were primitive
and disadvantaged, he reasoned,
perhaps introns had always
been present all the way back
to the last common ancestor and
had subsequently been streamlined
out of the prokaryotic
lineage, enabling them to adapt
in a different way
to their environment.
So this became known as the
introns early theory, okay?
Well, Gilbert liked this idea.
It pushed exon shuffling
back earlier in evolution
than he'd thought, so he had to
relinquish the Cambrian explosion,
but shuffling and in return he
gained evolutionary primacy,
this was a fundamental
thing in evolution.
So that seemed a good tradeoff.
And he wrote up this idea as a now
classic essay, why genes in pieces?
This appeared in February of 1978
and Ford Doolittle's response
appeared two months later in April.
In a conference paper
titled Playgrounds
of Evolution published the
next year Gilbert argued
that if exons were mini genes
then they ought to correspond
to functional protein
domains, right?
They ought to have made
functional things at one point
and if they were mixed and matched
to put together more complex things
you ought to see them correspond
when you look at more
complicated proteins,
such as this immunoglobulin
molecule, okay?
And so the pool of
exons and the genome
at any given time would
provide a set of Lego-like parts
from which evolution could
draw to make complex proteins.
He concluded poetically that exons
were inserted into a background
of noncoding DNA, like bubbles
he wrote the exons float
on a sea of introns.
In 1980 Gilbert received a
Nobel Prize for DNA sequencing.
In his Nobel lecture he
talked about DNA sequencing,
but he also spent a lot
of time discussing
evolution and exon shuffling.
So clearly these ideas were
all linked in his mind.
Well, Doolittle began
to diverge from Gilbert.
Evolution, he said, can't think
ahead and invent things in order
to speed future evolution, right?
In 1980, jumping off from
Richard Dawkin's argument
that an organism is a gene's way of
making more genes, Doolittle said
in essence, wait a second,
not all DNA is genes,
any DNA that replicates
itself ought to spread whether
or not it encodes a protein.
This suggests that a lot of
DNA should merely be junk,
and this is the origin of
the notion of junk DNA,
which you've probably heard.
Francis Crick and Leslie Orgel
had roughly the same idea
at the same time, selfish DNA they
said could be considered parasitic
because it takes metabolic energy
to make and to maintain it,
so it should have some cost
to the organism, right?
And they published the ideas back
to back in the Journal Nature.
It was on this background
- did I go forward, okay -
it was on this background then
that catalytic RNA was discovered.
In 1982 working with the
eukaryotic pond animal tetrahymena,
pictured here on the left, Tom
Cech at Colorado found an intron
in a ribosomal RNA gene that spliced
itself out of the messenger RNA.
It didn't require another
enzyme to come in
and cut it up, it could
just hop out.
The next year Sid Altman at Yale
published a paper on RNase P,
which is an enzyme that has a
protein part and an RNA part,
and what it does is snip off part
of the transfer RNA and activate it.
And accidentally in a control
experiment he found that one
of his technicians actually found
that the RNA component alone
could catalyze that reaction,
and so this was a big surprise.
So we have two examples back
to back of catalytic RNA,
now we know that this
can actually happen.
So these papers caused a sensation
accompanied by much speculation.
And so in 1985 Norm Pace, another
member of the Carl Woese age,
suggested that Cech's self-splicing
introns could be parasitic,
selfish transposons,
ala Crick and Doolittle.
He also proposed an RNA world.
He suggested that originally RNA
could have served as both genotype
and phenotype, in other words,
as both gene and enzyme.
So this is an important idea
because it links this intron idea
and selfish DNA to the idea of
RNA as the original molecule.
But Gilbert stuck to his guns,
the same year he revisited
his exon theory of genes,
comparing it against the data
that had been gathered since 1978.
In some cases the predictions
bore him out, in other cases not.
Ever the optimist he concluded
that the glass was half full,
the exon theory of genes, he
said, had held up rather well.
This then is the context
for Gilbert's classic paper,
which we can call The
RNA Only World.
He opened the paper with the
recent discoveries of RNA splicing,
but they were several
years old by this time,
why an editorial at this moment?
Because the paper was
as much about introns
as it was about RNA splicing.
Most people quote the deservedly
famous line from the paper,
one can contemplate an RNA world
containing only RNA molecules
that serve to catalyze the
synthesis of themselves.
And this then is the
classical RNA world described
with Gilbert's characteristic
literary flare.
But the paper also stated this
picture of the RNA world is one
of replicating molecules
that re-assort exons
by transposable elements
created by introns, okay?
So in a recent e-mail
Gilbert confirmed,
my stress in the RNA world
paper, he said, was twofold.
One was being struck with
the idea of RNA splicing,
with the idea of RNA enzymes
doing everything, he said,
and the second was the RNA based
exon shuffling of RNA pieces
as a way of speeding up evolution.
But the second idea would be written
out of the received narrative.
Gilbert's paper led to a Cold Spring
Harbor Symposium the next year
in which one of our participants,
Stephen Bennett, participated.
He may be hiding behind that tree
or maybe that's his
shoulder, I'm not sure.
But a published volume followed in
1993 with later editions in 1999,
2005, 2010, the RNA world
became a plurality of worlds
as new research revealed many new
roles for RNA molecules in the cell.
Today RNA world denotes a world
of contemporary physiology as much
as one of chemical evolution.
RNA world became a mean.
Here's an image taken from Carl
Zimmer's Science Tattoo Emporium,
in which a guy got a
tattoo of the RNA world,
except that he changed
the RNA to DNA
because he thought it looked better,
so the double helix looked cool.
So here's an RNA world
with no RNA, okay?
And the received version of the
history of the RNA world began
to crystalize within the scientific
community, roughly the one
with which I began, the
chicken-and-egg thing, okay?
This quote from Crick and Orgel
in 1993 represents an
act of myth making.
You can see all the elements of that
first RNA world that I described
to you at the beginning here.
The RNA world, he said, they called
retrospectively the most important
novel concept relevant
to our papers of 1968.
We were thinking about it, you know,
it's just we didn't have a name yet.
That he goes straight
to Cech and Altman,
he talks about specific
catalysts made of RNA,
not about exon shuffling,
and the key idea
of being a biochemistry
based on RNA alone.
All right, I'm not calling them out
as doing something really unusual.
This kind of thing
shouldn't be surprising.
Internal histories almost
always work this way, okay?
Workers in the field make tacit
decisions about what counts
as being worth passing down
to students, what and who does
and does not deserve
credit and so forth.
So my point here, though, is
that nif making has consequences.
There's a politics and a culture
to which stories are called true.
So I've shown you several RNA
worlds - the RNA protein world,
the selfish RNA world, the RNA only
world, and a constructed RNA world.
All of them are real and
all of them are imagined.
It's incontrovertible that RNA lies
at the heart of many fundamental
and ancient biological
processes, and it's nearly certain
that RNA preceded DNA in evolution.
But beyond that these are models,
right, they can guide experiments
but they can never be proven.
That makes them incredibly
interesting
as a historical topic, right?
The plurality of worlds may be,
in fact, not a flaw but a virtue.
The power of the RNA world may
lie precisely in its ambiguity,
in its existence as a
kind of virtual reality
in which we all see
what we want to see.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Are we going to just go on
to the next or do you want
to take a few questions now?
[ Inaudible ]
Okay, yes, sure.
So if there are any
questions I'll be glad to.
Yes? Hi.
>> Just curious, couldn't
more than one
of those worlds exist
at the same time?
>> Nathaniel Comfort:
Let's see, in what sense?
I mean there either
was protein, either RNA
and protein evolved simultaneously
or they didn't, right?
So which ones would you
think could be simultaneous?
>> Well, it's a big world and things
could happen in different places
and in different orders, making
the world much more complex
than we would like.
>> Nathaniel Comfort:
Yes, absolutely right.
>> And so that's why I was thinking,
wait a minute, why is it only one?
>> Nathaniel Comfort:
Right, right, right.
I didn't mean to imply that
there need be only one.
These are different models.
What I've found in the field
is that people glom onto one
and they defend it,
you know, vigorously.
Yes, fiercely in many cases.
But, of course, there's no reason
to suspect that at some point
in one privileged part of the
ocean a single cell drifted
up to the surface and
began photosynthesizing.
You know, it could have - many
people line-up with Matt Schrenk
and think that deep sea hydrothermal
vents are a very logical place
for life to have begun,
but those existed in lots
of different conditions, and there
are still people arguing that, no,
life probably emerged on
land in ponds that evaporated
and had repeated cycles
of drying and wetting.
The vent people say, yes,
there wasn't any land yet,
but that's a whole separate debate.
So, yes, you're right, in that
sense it's theoretically possible
that you could have an RNA only
world in one system and somewhere
around the globe maybe protein
evolves at the same time.
Yes, David, and then ...
>> I was in my mind thinking a
question and debating whether
to ask it, but it strikes
me that it's closely related
in an interesting way possibly
to the previous question.
I was wondering about how
deterministic this might be in terms
of being an astrobiologist,
thinking about other planets
and the process you're describing
might we expect something analogous
or even identical on other worlds?
If it's not so deterministic
and it could happen different
ways then it strikes me
that the previous question is
relevant, that it could happen
in different ways in different
locations on the earth.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Yes.
>> And possibly the interaction
between what's happening
in similar nearby environments
could complicate the picture,
there may not be one linear
progression in one place,
the geography of difference
could even become a part of this.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: That's great.
Thank you.
That's a really good point.
And I would say that's an example
of why the history matters, right?
If we accept the received version
of the history then we think there's
only one RNA world, but if we look
at the way the scientists were
thinking and writing and talking
and who were the different
allegiances and groups
that were debating and what the
real stakes were then we're kind
of freed up intellectually.
We can think about
different kinds of RNA world
and maybe there's one
RNA world on one world
and another RNA world
on another world, right?
So that's what I mean by the
received history having stakes
and why that matters
to uncover them.
So thank you.
Yes?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Oh, he's here.
>> Okay, the systems of RNA
world implies replication,
so it means that there should
have been double-stranded RNA,
so that, too, was not wrong.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: So
you're absolutely right,
and I knew somebody was
going to ask that question.
I think Carl will back me up and
say that the caption from the guy
with the tattoo said that
he substituted DNA for RNA
because it looked better.
But you're absolutely right,
RNA can be double-stranded.
So I think the guy
missed an opportunity,
he made himself unnecessarily
look a little bit like a doofus.
He could have just said, oh, yes,
it's double-stranded RNA, yes.
So, all right.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Oh, Carl, did
you want to chime in on that or?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Nathaniel Comfort:
Separate question, okay.
Mary?
>> So I have two things.
One is I think most
of the astrobiology community
is leaning towards the idea
that life probably arose many
times, which is consistent with lots
of different RNA worlds potentially,
and that what we are observing here
on earth at this moment is
the linear [Assumed Spelling].
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Right, yes.
>> So rewinding I'm sure you'd
see a lot of possibilities.
The other thing I would say
that is a challenge I think
for the metabolism first people and,
Matt, maybe I should have asked you,
I'll ask you again wherever you are.
>> Nathaniel Comfort:
Matt is right over here.
>> There you are.
Is that I don't know
that we actually know
when plate tectonics was initiated
and was pervasive on the planet
and hydrothermal vents are largely
driven by those sorts of activity,
so they may have been
late to the game, as well.
And so and maybe after
we had continents.
I mean a lot of this the geologic
history of earth becomes sort
of complicating in the whole picture
of how, what the origins were.
>> Nathaniel Comfort:
Yes, thank you for that.
One of the many mind-blowing
things that has happened
to be me this year was a few
weeks ago when you hooked me
up with Penny Boston
[Assumed Spelling],
the new head of the National
Astrobiology Institute.
And she is a geologist who goes
down in caves, and she told me -
she spun this whole model of the
amazing bacterial and archaeal life
down in, way down deep in the crust,
even possibly into the
mantle of the earth.
And said that a lot of that could
have predated plate tectonics,
and some of those organisms
might have been shifting
around with the tectonic plates.
And that means that life possibly
could have even predated the late
heavy bombardment.
I mean so we could be
pushed back even before
that 3.7 billion years, right?
So she has this remarkable vision
of not - we're used to thinking
of the world as a big
rock clothed with life,
and her concept is an integrated
mineral, biogeological system,
that rock and life are
inherently integrated.
And think about that, if a little
drop of sweat occurs on your brow
in here, what's in it,
salt, minerals, right?
So we're constantly, life is flowing
through rock and rock is flowing
through life constantly, right?
So, yes. So I told her, yes.
So we finished the
conversation by my saying,
can I come down in a cave?
And she said, sure.
So, you know, I can't wait.
Any more? Carl had one?
>> I am just curious
sort of historically,
like as you've been looking at the
RNA world as it was being explored,
described and so on in its different
forms, how much were people thinking
of it as an investigation of the
origin of life versus a transition
with something before it,
then you go to RNA life,
and then you get to
RNA-DNA protein life?
I'm sort of wondering because you
showed the feathered dinosaur,
you know, and that's a
great transitional form
and there you're just sort
of wondering like, okay,
how did birds get in
the air with feathers?
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Right.
>> And then you look
at those dinosaurs.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Right.
>> And so the RNA world in that
case might be this transitional form
and maybe you got something else
before it, maybe some molecules,
like PNA or something, that
aren't even around anymore.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Right.
>> I'm just curious like when the
people were historically developing
the idea of the RNA world
how were they framing it?
Were they saying like we
go from nothing to RNA
or were they saying
something and then RNA
and that addresses this
basic transition question?
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Right, okay.
>> Magic.
>> Nathaniel Comfort:
Someone with magic, yes.
One of the things that interests
me about the RNA world is
that it is precisely at
that transitional place.
And you have one group of scientists
who tend to work downward,
working down the phylogenetic
tree back
to the last universal
common ancestor and trying
to drive back down to the RNA world.
You have another group who
are coming up from the geology
and basically trying to make
life out of rocks and seawater.
And the RNA world sits right in the
middle there, and some people think
that that would be life
and some people think
that that's a pre-proto life.
Originally, the first people,
like Crick and Orgel and Gilbert,
had a pretty - as I said, they're
basically practicing evolution
without a license, and so they
had a pretty simplistic kind
of primordial soup notion that
there would just be this pool
of nucleotides floating around that
would gather together into strands
of RNA that would replicate,
and then there would be some amino
acids floating around in the pool
and they would somehow
glom onto them, right?
So they didn't really
think about that.
And one of the really exciting
things to me this year was to get
to talk to and read a whole
bunch about the people
who were working bottom-up, right?
And it's too bad that Jim Cleaves
isn't here because he thinks
of himself as going sideways,
coming at it from a different angle.
But that's one of the things that
has come out of the last few decades
of origin of life research, that
this really is an area where,
you know - and this is why the
ambiguity I think is valuable
because you can toss around a term
like RNA world and everybody kind
of knows what you mean, and so
you say we're trying to get,
ideally we'd like to
get from dinucleotides
and the reverse TCA cycle up to
the RNA world, whatever that is.
And other people would say,
you know, well, this could lead
down to eventually the RNA
world, and those people can talk
to each other because there's
enough slippage in the term
that it enables people
with different languages
to speak to each other.
Yes, okay, I think with
that I will leave it.
We'll have more time for a
general discussion afterward,
but I don't want to take
any time away from Matt.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Matt Schrenk: All right.
Thank you.
All right, well, first
off, it's a real honor
and a privilege to be speaking.
And I'll thank you and you
Nathaniel for inviting me
into the Kluge Center
for hosting this event.
I'm really excited not only
to tell you about the research
that my lab group conducts and the
places we've been, but also to hear
from the range of different studies
that are being conducted by people
in this room and the vast amount
of knowledge related to this topic
that they bring to the table.
So my group at Michigan State
studies modern microorganisms
in extreme environments.
Many of these are geothermal
systems, hot environments,
at the bottom of the ocean
and associated with volcanoes.
Some of the sponsors of our work
include NASA Astrobiology Institute,
as well as the Deep
Carbon Observatory
and the Alfred P. Sloane Foundation.
And so we look at this
interface between geological
and biological processes
in modern systems.
Let's see, all right.
So I'm going to provide a
little bit of context related
to the early earth environment
and origins of life theories
because I wasn't sure
exactly what some
of the other speakers
were covering today.
But really I wanted to get into some
of the insights we have from looking
at these modern systems, describing
what these systems are all
about first and foremost and
then subsequently what are some
of the characteristics of the
geomicrobiology in these systems
and how they might stimulate future
directions to consider in origins
of life research, both from the
bottom-up and top-down sorts
of approaches or perhaps
even sideways approaches
if you can imagine that.
So, as Nathaniel said earlier, the
warm little pond is at the window,
but just to point out and put this
into context it's the ideas dating
back to Darwin and even further back
to Pasteur and others, thinking
about organosynthesis reactions,
these warm little ponds
stimulated by heat or electricity
or light originating some
of the first biomolecules
and subsequently the
first organisms.
Thereby serving as
inspiration for experiments
like the Miller-Urey
synthesis experiment in 1953,
where they took water in a highly
reducing atmosphere with things
like methane and hydrogen
and ammonia and create,
used a spark discharge
to generate some
of the first abiologically
produced amino acids at that point.
Now it turns out that that system
was a whole lot more complicated
than the initial experiment
suggested
that perhaps the early atmosphere
was not as reduced, for example,
as the Urey experiment, but it
really stimulated a long line
of experimental research
into the possibilities
for organosynthesis reactions.
And whether you think
the conditions were right
or not it's become apparent over
the years through explorations
of the solar system and the
organic matter contained
within these objects
within our solar system
that organosynthesis reactions
occur and are widespread in space.
For example, in the
atmosphere of some
of these icy moves [Assumed
Spelling], such as Titan,
you have UV stimulated
radiation of simple molecules,
of small molecules, synthesis
reactions continuing on
and thereby creating more and
more complex organic molecules.
Also, through the exploration
of meteorites and comets
and the very high levels
of these materials
that were hitting the earth during
the Hadean period, all these,
in particular the carbonaceous
chondrites are very organic-rich,
so they contain a range of
organic compounds, you know,
macromolecular carbon can comprise
70% to 80% of the total carbon,
for example, in these materials and
they contain a range of compounds,
including amino acids,
aromatics, purines and pyrimidines.
So some of these building blocks
of these larger organic molecules
that we've been talking about.
So, and then my favorite
topic, the hydrothermal events,
so these are areas associated
with primarily magnetic
upwelling in the earth.
They serve to drive
the input of seawater
and hydrothermal circulation
up to 65 millions
of years away from the ridge axis.
They were first discovered
in the late 1970s
and they've really revolutionized
many areas of science,
including microbiology
and our understanding
of evolutionary biology and
biodiversity on this planet.
Some of the most apparent
life forms there are things
like the giant tubeworms, shown
on the right-hand side here,
but there's underlying this there's
a rich diversity of microbial life
in these systems, as well.
So these systems have very steep
gradients in both temperature
and chemistry associated with them.
As the cool oxidized seawater,
at least in the modern day earth,
percolates through the
subsurface, it's heated up,
reacts with subsurface rocks and
then is vented onto the sea floor,
containing high temperature
fluids up to 407 degrees Celsius,
rich in dissolved metals,
and also shows the potential
for abiogenic synthesis, okay?
So there were numerous sources
of heat on the Hadean earth,
heat from accretion,
radiolytic decay and energy
from meteoritic impacts
that potentially drive
hydrothermal circulation.
These systems are rich in
catalytic mineral surfaces.
These systems are generally
made of metal sulfide materials.
And perhaps with all
this bombardment
and this very harsh surface
environment perhaps subsurface
environments associated with
these systems protected proto life
and even some of the
early molecular reactions
from the damaging affects
of all these impacts.
And nowadays there's evidence
for a prolific abiogenic
organosynthesis reactions,
abiogenetically produced
organic molecules,
particularly at ultramafic-hosted
hydrothermal vents.
These are rocks that are more
reducing, commonly characteristic
of deeper portions of the
earth, such as the mantle,
that stimulate the production of
high concentrations of hydrogen,
as well as abiogenic
small organic molecules.
So my point was not to
focus on any one of these,
not even on deep-sea
hydrothermal vents in particular.
The point is that there
are many different sources
of organic molecules likely to
have occurred on the early earth
and all these likely played
some role in this system.
Additionally, you know, as Nathaniel
talked about quite a bit in his talk
as well or at least the RNA
world component of this,
there are several problems we need
to solve when it comes to going
from these abiotic organosynthesis
reactions to the first cells
or the first things we could
recognize as living organisms.
The extent to which we need
membranes to encapsulate
and protect some of these early
biomolecules and reactions
and the order in which that occurred
and the whole chicken-and-egg
scenario.
Our ability to catalyze larger
and more complex molecules
under appropriate chemistries,
it's a continual work in progress
in terms of making things that
are more functional and productive
in terms of the relationship
to the first cells.
And then thinking about
how these properties,
how these success stories
are then inherited
and these emergent properties
propagate through the system
and are stored in information
storage, whether those are
in minerals, DNA, RNA
or other molecules.
So we're still a long ways from
the first functioning protocells.
We still have a lot of work
to do to connect the dots
from the bottom-up and the top-down.
But what I do think is important
is I think, and I forget which one
of the people in the audience
asked this, I think it was David,
about the complexity of
these natural systems.
It's likely that there was not just
one location for these reactions
to be occurring, it's likely
that they were all
occurring simultaneously
or perhaps there is some sort
of temporal aspect, as well,
but there's complexity
in the environment,
it's not just a warm little pond
or a beaker full of chemicals,
it's a moving dynamic system moving
through space and moving
through time.
As my Ph.D. advisor has put it,
John Barose [Assumed Spelling],
for a number of years,
original life probably occurred
as a one-kilometer cell connecting
many different environments.
So people, like Mike Russell,
have taken this and developed
and articulated models
connecting some of these thermal
and chemical gradients and how
they might drive the synthesis
of organic molecules and
some of the first cells,
some of the first things
resembling protocells.
Using the natural physical
and chemical characteristics
of environments, like hydrothermal
vent chimneys, as templates
or analogs for some of
these reactions to occur.
John Barose's group, with
the lead Author Eva Stueken,
put out this really nice paper a
few years ago in geobiology sort
of tying together not just at
the hydrothermal vent scale
but at the global scale
how earth could serve
as a global chemical reactor
providing different catalysts
and different reaction
conditions as part
of a dynamic system
encompassing many
of the different inputs we've
talked about already - meteorites,
atmospheric chemistry
and hydrothermalism.
So the world is complex,
it's complex now,
and it was complex back four
billion year ago, as well.
And I think we need to take
this complexity and diversity
into account rather than being
pigeonholed into a particular type
of reaction or region
where it can occur.
So, as I mentioned, the
ancient earth was complex,
but so is the modern earth.
This is an example of a
heavily serpentinized rock,
a water rock reaction.
The microbes, this is
a common sort of system
that my laboratory studies, one type
of system where water is flowing
through subsurface materials.
All this mosaic and mosaic fracture
network here are the habitats
in which microorganisms
and these systems occur.
But I'm not an organic chemist,
I'm not a paleontologist or any
of these things, my laboratory
studies environmental biology.
We get out in the field, we go
to extreme environments
and we collect samples.
We try to figure out how
the microbes are operating,
how they survive these
conditions, how they interact
with the geochemical and
physical environments.
And then if there are clues within
these systems that tell us something
as analogs to earlier conditions,
you know, I think they can be used
to inform some of these
bottom-up types of approaches.
But the other thing that
I haven't heard mentioned
yet that I think is really valuable
about these types of environments is
that these are systems
on the modern day earth
where you have this interface
of abiotic and biotic processes.
As you drill down deeper into
the earth you cross some divide
or you're likely to
cross some divide.
We haven't reached
it yet in some cases,
between abiotic carbon cycling
and the biosphere, right?
And we need to study
these systems carefully
and understand how organisms
in these systems might use
these abiotic compounds and how
to define the properties of
living and nonliving systems.
So the point is I think the
environments I'm going to describe
in just a second here have
values not just as analogs
for early earth type of conditions,
but also as observatories,
places to look to better understand
the relationship between living
and nonliving parts of the earth.
So one of our favorite types
of systems is the deep-sea
hydrothermal vents.
Here's a typical example
of that here.
These are places in the
middle of the ocean.
There's 65,000 kilometers along the
ocean ridge spreading center network
on the planet right now
where seawater percolates
through the subsurface, reacts
with the rock, and then is vented
out through these hydrothermal vent
chimneys known as black smokers.
Within the subsurface and within
the walls of these chimneys,
which can be tens of
meters off of the sea floor,
you have really steep gradients
in temperature and chemistry
between the 300 plus degrees
Celsius hydrothermal fluids
and the 2 degrees Celsius seawater.
These fluids are also very diverse
in terms of their chemistry.
The hydrothermal fluid
is full of metals,
which make this the black smoke
that's coming out of the chimney,
whereas, the seawater is largely
oxic and has a variety of compounds
that can be used potentially
to oxidize or respire some
of these components coming out
of the hydrothermal fluids.
Just a few years ago or now it's
been more than a few years ago,
but back in 2000 a new type
of hydrothermal system was
discovered called the Lost City
hydrothermal field.
This was discovered near the
Mid-Atlantic Ridge by a group
of researchers at the
University of Washington,
and the differences
here are that instead
of having very high temperature
hydrothermal fluids coming
out that are very acidic
and metal rich,
here you have fluids influenced by
a process called serpetinization,
which are very high pH and rich,
even higher concentrations
of methane and hydrogen.
So these are a completely
different sort of chemistry
than you typically see at the black
smoker type of magnetic systems.
More moderate temperatures
in the sense,
and typically where these
things occur are not places
where magnetic activity
occurs, but these are associated
with commonly tectonic activity,
earthquakes, that offset the plates
from one another and
allow fluids to circulate.
And then a third type of system we
work at are subaerial volcanoes.
So, in particular, we
look at microbes that live
within these volcanic
fumaroles and try
to study how they're using
all this gas that's coming
out of these fumaroles.
These gases can include
hydrogen, sulfur compounds,
things that you might
see in sketches
of what the early earth
might look like.
these things are occurring
right now in places
like Komatke [Assumed Spelling] in
Siberia And the Aleutian Islands
and all along the ring of
fire, really, in the Pacific.
So here you have materials
that accumulates
on the ocean floor then subducted
back into the earth and some
of this sways back out through
these extreme environments found
in subaerial volcanoes.
So I just want to make a
couple points about our studies
of these sorts of systems.
The first of which is organisms
in these systems don't grow
in your typical flask or beaker
full of material, they don't grow
in a liquid phase commonly.
These systems are dynamic systems.
If Nathaniel showed you
some pictures of his trip
to Yellowstone this summer he might
show you streamers and biofilms,
slimy communities growing
in the outflow
from the hydrothermal pools there.
The organisms in these systems
want to stay attached to surfaces,
they want to stay in
their happy place in terms
of these thermal-chemical gradients.
And they grow attached to these
catalytic mineral surfaces,
so many of the same surfaces
and minerals we evoke to serve
as catalysts in our abiogenic
synthesis reactions are also the
substrates for microbes to grow on.
So here's an example of microbes
that grew on the surface of a piece
of iron sulfide or pyrite mineral
that we stuck in a
hydrothermal vent.
You can see they form colonies,
they divide, they disperse,
and they pattern themselves
all over this surface.
At the Lost City hydrothermal field
this serpetinization influenced high
pH system.
There's also interesting
insights from looking at biofilms.
For example, when we go into
the hydrothermal chimneys
at the Lost City we see almost a
single species of biofilms comprised
of archaea related to
methanogenic archaea
within these hydrothermal
vent chimneys.
The picture on the upper right
here shows some of the polymers,
these polymeric matrix that
holds these cells together.
In this sense it's dehydrated,
but these organisms are
encapsulated together
in a bed of slime, more or less.
This biofilms are held
together and attached
to the surfaces using polymers,
such as polysaccharides,
which keep them in place.
So the point of this is not only
do the organisms have some sort
of very tightly coupled interaction
with the catalytic surfaces,
but they grow as communities
in these polymers
and this polymeric matrix, this gel,
might serve some important roles
in terms of thinking about how
different organosynthesis reactions
may couple together to form
some of the first protocells.
They may also serve as templates for
minerals, especially nano particles
and small scale minerals that may
also serve as catalysts to occur.
So these charged biofilms,
these gel-like matrices can
instigate the precipitation
of small minerals.
These minerals may serve
as more effective catalysts
when dispersed throughout the film.
So this is another part where even
the properties of the biofilm,
itself, even if they aren't
cellular may serve a role
in facilitating some of the
early prebiotic chemistry
and organosynthesis reactions.
So for one thing I would encourage
studying these small scale
properties and the role
of biofilms and polymers
in origins of life research.
The second thing is it's
very attractive to think
about using these metal
sulfide catalysts
or these different
metallic catalysts
to drive organosynthesis reactions.
We can show that simple
reactions occur fairly readily,
especially as you heat them to
higher temperatures and put them
under pressure, such as the
carbonyl insertion reaction shown
in the middle here.
We can also go out to
hydrothermal systems,
like the rainbow hydrothermal
field in the middle of the Atlantic
which is a hybrid system
between the high temperature
and the ultramafic
systems I've described
and find many different organic
molecules in the fluids coming
out of these, which have isotopic
signatures and chemical signatures
to show that they are
not produced by biology.
So we have both observational
experimental sense
that abiotic organic
geochemistry is happening
at modern day hydrothermal vents.
And it's attractive to look
at those data and then compare
that to biochemical
pathways that we know about.
For example, the reductive acetyl
CoA pathway and begin to plug
and play with the different
mineral catalysts and think
about how the different steps may
be catalyzed through the reaction.
But the reality of this and sort
of building upon what I was
describing earlier about the divide
between living and
nonliving systems are
that the world is not that simple.
There's overlapping carbon sources
and properties in all
of these systems.
What we've found through
studies of deep earth materials
and of hydrothermal systems is
that organisms don't always use the
simplest molecules to metabolize,
they don't always use the CO2 or the
hydrogen, sometimes they use some
of these simple organic compounds
produced by abiotic processes,
sometimes they use the hydrocarbons,
the methane and other compounds.
And so it's not always so
clear as to what's biotic
and abiotic in these systems.
Certainly interesting
to think about in terms
of astrobiological
exploration, right?
We'd like to know,
study these systems
and understand what's evidence
of life and what's not.
But as for exploring deeper parts
of the earth's biosphere right
now it's sometimes difficult to go
from a very simple
explanation like this
to the complexity of the real world.
So, again, I would encourage
studies of these analog type systems
in order to help us better
define the properties of abiotic
and biological carbon
compounds in these systems.
And then we haven't even gotten
into the fact that we're covered
with life on the surface and
that complicates everything,
it eats a lot of carbon
that's produced
and just makes it a big mess, right?
And then, thirdly, I want to talk
about we've had this in biology,
we've had this genomics revolution
over the past 20 years or so,
where nowadays we don't have to
deal with radioactive phosphorous
in terms of our sequencing,
like Maxam and Gilbert
and Sanger did in those days.
Nowadays we can just send
samples off on a plate
and have results overnight
or in very short order.
Many orders of magnitude, more
at DNA sequences than we used to.
Nowadays we're drowning
in data in many cases.
So this has really enabled us to
look at biology in a whole new way.
So an example of this
the really exciting paper
that was published just this summer
by Bill Martin's group
over in Germany.
Many of you have probably seen
something like this tree of life
in the upper right here, thinking
about the lineages of bacteria
and eukarya and archaea and how
they might have some last universal
common ancestry may have been shared
amongst these different lineages
and thinking about what that
last common ancestor was
and where it originated.
Many of these trees traditionally
have been built upon just a few
genes, primarily the small subunit
ribosomal RNA gene or 16S gene
that you may have heard about.
But this genomics revolution
I talked about has enabled us
to look not just at individual
genes, but across whole genomes
or bacterial chromosomes
to look at the properties
of not just the ribosomal RNA
gene but any sort of function
of phenotype that we
have some knowledge of.
So Martin's group looked at over
2,000 different prokaryotic genomes
from the sequencing
analyses and boiled it
down to 355 protein families
that were shared amongst multiple
lineages across the tree of life.
And what they found out was
that they found some clues
to the metabolic and
physiological properties of some
that were likely shared by the
last universal common ancestor
and that leuka was probably an
anaerobic thermophile likely related
to cluster of the LEs [Assumed
Spelling] or methanogens
and that things like
hydrogen, nitrogen
and carbon monoxide were all
important in its metabolism.
So some of these things
sound familiar
with what we've already described,
places like the Lost
City hydrothermal field
or deep-sea vents, so it's very
encouraging that these sort
of data were able to fall
out of this very complicated
and thorough analyses
that they conducted.
And but what Martin's group worked
with was only a fraction of what is
out there on the planet, so there's
long been this significant disjoint
between what we can obtain
and domesticate in the lab,
what we can culture, and what we
know exists in the environment.
Typically we're only able to
cultivate a very small percentage
of all the organisms
out there in nature,
particularly in extreme
environments that are not usually
on the radar of, say, medical
microbiologists, for example.
So we have a very small subset of
the organisms nature and culture
from these systems, but what we can
do using these new genomic tools is
to look at environmental genomes
to take DNA from the rocks,
squeeze DNA out of the rocks or
out of the sulfur and the fumaroles
and sequence all the genes
that are present there.
And the interesting thing through
my lab's study of these systems is
that many of the same
metabolisms and properties
that Martin's group saw through
their phylogenic analysis also fall
out of these environmental
genomes, so evidence for the role
of hydrogen, NCO, and
carbon monoxide
in these systems, for example.
The abundance of clostridia
in these systems
which we suspect might be playing
a role in acetate production
that can be utilized by other
components of the community.
And so we've done surveys
of many of these systems
for functional genes related to
and involving carbon
cycling and hydrogen cycling.
Shown here is a study from a site
we work at in Northern California
where ancient sea floors
arrived on the continents
and thereby enabled us to study
the subsurface at the site.
And so you can see numerous genes,
what is presented here is numerous
genes related to hydrogen cycling,
carbon cycling and carbon fixation
present in these high pH sites
where it's up to pH 12
in terms of the solution.
You can do phylogenetic analyses of
some of these genes and find, again,
through these environmental
genomic sequences that many
of these genes related to hydrogen,
oxidation or to carbon fixation come
from organisms, like
methanogens or clostridia.
Okay, so there's really fascinating
insights that are very complementary
to analyses of single organisms
and their phylogeny to come
out of environmental studies of
these natural extreme environments.
So I think there's a lot of
insight to be had from looking
from the top-down at these
systems, clues we can find
in both the physiology and
phylogeny of living organisms
in these environments
thought to be either analogs
or early earth environments
or at least places
where we can study the
relationships between abiotic
and biotic processes on the planet.
And I think there's in some
cases, as I mentioned before,
we're flooded with data in
many cases and so there's a lot
to be mined out of these datasets
that we haven't even
happened upon yet.
One of the studies in
particular that I enjoy is looking
at the metagene on the
environmental genome
of these single species
biofilms from Lost City
that we talked about earlier.
So this is like a single
population organism that grows
within these chimneys that is
bathed in pH 11 fluid at 90 degrees
and really seems to be
thriving in that system.
And I already pointed out some of
the roles of things like hydrogen,
carbon monoxide and methane in these
systems, but you can look at things
like transposases, so genes
involved in gene duplication
and replication within
these biofilms.
And what we found through the
study of the Lost City chimneys is
that something like 8% of sequencing
reads we found were associated
with transposases.
So order of magnitude more
of the reads are associated
with these gene duplications than
we'd seen in many other sorts
of systems, like farm soil and
bioreactor sludge and so on.
So these hydrothermal vent chimneys,
in particular, seem to be hotbeds
for genetic exchange
and diversification even
if on the surface they look
like they're a clonal
population of organisms.
And since this study
was published in 2009,
other studies of sulfide
chimneys have found similar -
the black smoker chimneys have found
similar sorts of relationships.
And so what this means is that it's
not just a single organism that has
to have all of the properties
to survive, that the organisms
within these biofilms can work
collectively and potentially carry
out multiple functions
within the biofilm.
So here's an example of
looking at nitrogenases,
nitrogen fixation genes
within these biofilms.
And we can see that even
though it looks homogeneous
from the standpoint of a species in
a traditional sense we had something
like 18 different nitrogenases
present in the biofilm,
so lots of genetic diversity
that's not immediately apparent.
And then additionally I wanted
to point out that we can,
we should be able to train in with
higher resolution on these systems
and look at the relationships
between the microbes growing
as biofilms and the
catalytic mineral surfaces.
There's no reason we need to
be carrying out experiments
on organosynthesis at 300
degrees Celsius in high pressures
in the absence of biology
and then train
to grow our organisms
at 100 degrees Celsius.
We should be able to better
replicate and study the systems
and how they overlap
in space and time.
And I'd like to finish up by saying
I think there's a lot of potential
to learn not just about how
processes work on our own planet,
but one of the best resources
we have out there is by looking
at these other planets and moons,
looking at the potential subsurface
ocean on Europa or the cryovolcanism
in icy plumes coming
out of Enceladus
or the hydrocarbon lakes
on the surface of Titan.
So all these systems, whether
they have biology emerging or not,
should be very interesting
comparisons
from our own planetary neighborhood
that ought to allow us to look back
into deep time and to think
about the conditions that led
to the emergence of life on this
planet versus in other locations.
And with the addition
of extra solar plants
to the menu we have even more
opportunities to consider
and compare and maybe find
another parallel life form existing
out there.
And so I'd like to finish
by saying thank you,
and I'd be happy to
take any questions.
[ Applause ]
>> Matt Schrenk: Sure, sounds great.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: That's
you, that's me, that's you.
>> Matt Schrenk: Okay.
I have myself over here.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: There you go.
>> Nsikan Akpan: Okay, is
everyone ready for the pop quiz?
[laughter] Great.
Does anyone have questions
for Matt, just to begin?
>> Matt Schrenk: Sure.
>> You mentioned that the carbonic
side is a critical molecule
for the [inaudible] processes
and it's also a critical molecule
for the prebiotic chemistry.
>> Matt Schrenk: Right.
>> In the primitive atmospheres.
And the question is that
what is the energy source
that basically creates the CO.
This is a [inaudible] question how
to create CO, which is
available for this processes?
>> Matt Schrenk: Typically,
as far as I understand it,
the carbon monoxide is created by
geologic processes, so it's produced
by degassing of earth materials
and it's a component of the fluids
that are coming out
of these systems.
So I mean that's my understanding
is the biology doesn't play a role
in producing the CO.
>> So [inaudible] associate CO2 and
actually it's not a small amount
of energy, it's not a fraction of
electro volts, it's more than that.
>> Matt Schrenk: Right.
>> So, and the second question is
that have you had the chance to look
at how a population on those fields
changes over some time scale?
Let's say that solar activity?
>> Matt Schrenk: I'm sorry,
what was the last part?
>> Like solar activity cycle,
let's say over 11 years,
have you had the ...
>> Matt Schrenk: I mean
there's been a number
of interesting opportunities.
I could point out just a few, one of
which is the single species biofilm
at Lost City that I
was talking about.
It hasn't changed, that's what's
been so interesting about that.
Site after site we sampled
there, year after year,
these same organisms exist
within those chimneys.
So it really must be
adapted to that environment.
In fact, the only other place
those organisms have been found is
recently a similar system was
discovered in New Caledonia
at the Bay of Prony with
hydrothermal chimneys like this
and the same organisms are
all over those integrated
within the carbonate chimneys there.
So it's a really interesting
system in terms of its uniqueness,
as well as the resilience
of this populations.
At the same time the black smoker
chimneys are incredibly diverse
and dynamic, so you've got meters
per second hydrothermal fluids
circulating through those, gradients
that select for different organisms
across those chimney walls.
So it's a very diverse system
and very subject to both regular
and episodic changes, so I mean
volcanoes, magma moves around
and volcanoes explode and it's not
a great long-term place to live
or just to be in the same
place at the same time.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: I could
just throw in there that some
of the scientists I've talked
to, such as Everett Shock
from Arizona State, goes to
Yellowstone and samples a set
of 60 hydrothermal
pools in a different,
a wide range of different kinds
of conditions - alkaline and basic
and hot and just warm and so forth.
And he's doing just that, a
longitudinal study, so he goes back
and samples the same set of
pools every year and is looking
at those kinds of long-term
temporal changes.
So, yes, this is a very exciting,
ongoing area of research.
>> Nsikan Akpan: And so your
last comment actually feeds
into the first question that
I had in terms of tempo.
I talked to Dr. Cleaves before
I came and he said, you know,
we don't know if this happened in
a weekend, these processes happened
in a weekend or if they
happened in a million years,
so you had to have a precise
set or a precise sequence occur.
So how do we find that out in
modern time or what signs do we look
for either here or on a moon,
like Enceladus or Europa?
>> Matt Schrenk: I mean I think
it's a problem with many sorts
of the experiments we do, even
if our question was something
as tractable as let's
try to grow some
of these organisms we
can't grow in the lab,
the issue we might face
is the issue of time.
It might be that the organisms
divide once every 100 years
or 300 years and that's out
of scale with our lifetimes,
let alone a Ph.D. student's career.
[laughter] So that's one
problem we face anyhow,
but without knowing the sequence of
events or even having a full list
of all the events that need to occur
I think it would be very difficult
to constrain.
But in my opinion the best approach
might be to look at a variety
of different analogs and get a sense
at what those time scales might be,
so we can look at remnants
of the early earth
within our own solar system
and where we can look at places
that had similar materials
but maybe didn't progress
to having recognizable life.
Anyhow, we have a lot of
opportunities for observations
to make that perhaps could feed
into models to help us come
up with experiments that a
Ph.D. student could actually do.
>> Nsikan Akpan: Right, perfect.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Yes, so one of
the things that interests me as I go
around and talk to these folks is
just that question of are we talking
about - if you're trying to
reconstruct these early systems,
you know, how you get
a living system
from rocks and seawater and heat.
Do you have, is it a gradual process
of chemical systems
forming simple molecules
and over time putting themselves
together or do you build a system
that is ready and then you
pull the trigger and go, right?
I mean that's a really
interesting question.
>> Nsikan Akpan: Right here?
>> Thank you.
When you talked about going from say
an RNA world to an RNA protein world
or something like that, protein is
basically a bunch of amino acids
that get tied together by
some sort of enzyme or RNA.
And initially you get a whole
bunch of abiotic amino acids,
but eventually they've
got to be synthesized.
And has anybody looked
at the mechanisms
for synthesizing the amino acids
and how they may have evolved
and whether there are
parallel different mechanisms
which could have originated
separately?
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Yes, I mean
I'm sure Matt has something to say
about that, but among the people
that I've been talking to, you know,
as I look at and talk to different
people working on the origin of life
from different angles it seems to me
that everybody has their own model
and they get so far
down or so far up.
And then at some point everybody
says and then magic happens, right?
[laughter] And so I've started
to think about this zone of magic
and what exactly is that?
And kind of everybody zeroing
in, homing in on it somehow.
And that right there is to me the
heart of the zone of magic, right?
How do you get nucleotides
associated with amino acids
so that they are ordering them
and polymerizing them into chains
to build things that
actually do something,
that catalyze further
reactions, right?
So people are looking at that
and trying to find out ways
in which you can get, say, small
nucleotides, strings of nucleotides
that can trigger, create
a peptide bond and link
to amino acids together, right?
>> Creating the amino
acids, themselves?
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Creating
the amino acids themselves.
Those can fall out of things
like the acetyl coenzyme,
a pathway that Matt described
or the reverse TCA cycle,
what we know as the orthocreb
[Assumed Spelling] cycle.
Different parts of those metabolic
pathways you can produce both
nucleotides and amino acids,
as well as lipids, yes.
>> Matt Schrenk: I think
there are numerous sources
of at least the amino
acids, themselves,
that could have fed
into these models.
It's this question of associating
those amino acids into proteins
and then relating that to the RNA
or DNA, whatever the molecule is
that you're going to follow-up on.
>> Nsikan Akpan: And so
that actually makes me think
of a question that I had
during your talk, Nathaniel.
You mentioned how Gilbert went
from seeing spaces to modularity,
and I was wondering do
you know anything about
or has your research
shown anything about how
that thought process
happened for him?
How do you go from, you
know, DNA or RNA or genes,
which we typically think
of as like words on a page
and if you're missing those words
on the page then how do you
think, oh, it must be ...
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Yes,
so as I said, this is ongoing
and I'm trying - I'm still
like I've got long enough
from Gilbert earlier this
week that actually filled
in several phases for me.
And this idea of the exons
floating on a sea of introns, right,
that process, I narrowed it
down to somewhere probably
during 1978, all right?
And or late '77, and I'm still
trying to get - the problem is
that people construct their own
narratives of what happened,
and as an oral historian part of my
job is to cut across those stories
that they've been telling for so
many years and get them to kind
of break through and reconstruct
their thought processes
in a new way that's different from
their kind of canonical narrative.
I actually had to persuade one
of the actors for Doolittle
that this was one way of
telling the RNA world story.
When I explained it
to him he said, yeah,
that is a legitimate
way of telling it.
But he had bought and told
the conventional story.
>> Nsikan Akpan: Right,
he had his own version,
the version that he liked to tell.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Yes.
I want to just call on
Mary, who I think wanted
to jump in on that last point?
>> Nsikan Akpan: Oh, sure.
>> Mary Voytek: Yes, I heard your
question a little differently
and so I'm going to answer
it slightly different
in that it is very easy
to make an amino acid.
They're made in all sorts
of different places.
You don't need a cycle that's driven
by a biological system
and metabolism.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: True.
>> Mary Voytek: We find amino acids
all throughout basically our solar
system and maybe the rest of the
universe, we find them in meteorites
that we know are not biological, and
you can get polymerization of them,
not with a particular order
or not directed, I should say,
as in the system, but you
can get small polypeptides,
you can certainly get
dipeptides and tripeptides
without invoking anything but -
and a lot of reactions and a lot
of biomolecule precursors are made
without any biology involved in it.
>> Nathaniel Comfort:
Yes, thank you very much.
I mean that kind of stems -
actually, as I said that I realized
that that's also an
important answer.
So thanks for chiming
in on that, yes.
>> Nsikan Akpan: And over here?
>> I'm a little bit concerned that
you keep bringing hydrothermal vents
as opposed to geothermal vents.
I thought we thoroughly vetted them
because in life hydrothermal vents
would be diluted, poisoned by sodium
and have no energy to survive.
And these Martin comments have
been just thoroughly refuted
by Buzz Jackson [Assumed Spelling]
in general medical evolution
from a purely thermodynamic point of
view, which I argued 15 years ago.
So what are your arguments
in favor of hydrothermal
as opposed to geothermal vents?
Thank you.
>> Matt Schrenk: The
points I was trying to get
across was not necessarily an
argument in favor of hydrothermal
or even deep-sea hydrothermal vents.
I actually was, have been
very influenced by this idea
of connected environments.
It's a near certainty meteorites
and their components were hitting
the planet early on and in many
of these systems you're confronted
with the same problems of dilution
and trying to concentrate
things on surfaces.
So one thing to recognize
about these systems,
whether it's a geothermal
or hydrothermal system,
is that they're a system in motion.
So the reaction conditions
that synthesize molecules
at 300 degrees Celsius or
whatever don't stay in that place
for any great length of time.
In many cases they move on to
some other catalytic environment.
So what I favor is this
idea of connectivity
between different types of systems.
I think going from
observations of fluid circulations
to multifaceted model of bubbles
and particle formation is, you know,
a few steps removed from what we
observe in the natural systems,
but I think by studying the natural
systems we can learn something
about how these places actually
function from a physical
and chemical perspective.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Do you think
it makes sense to think instead
of this idea of life popping
out of the ocean or wherever
at some magical moment in time,
rather the earth becoming a
biotic, a geobiotic system?
>> Matt Schrenk: I think at
a global scale that's likely,
I mean that's what's
happened, there's people
and animals and bacteria, elephants.
But in terms of, you know, I think
even locally, even within the scale
of a few kilometers or the scale is
larger than individual protocells,
connected processes
likely played a role
in this before the widespread
takeover of the planet.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Yes, okay.
>> Nsikan Akpan: And
so we'll take a handful
of questions before we
have to hop off the stage.
Right there?
>> Yes, I'm Ronald Wilson
with the Federal Government.
My question is if scientists ever
can firmly establish the origin
of life?
What do you see as the probable
implications and significance
of that for humanity, mankind,
society and this universe,
which probably will come to
an end at some point in time?
>> Nathaniel Comfort: We can
probably come up with a scientific
and a historical answer
to that question.
You want to go?
>> Matt Schrenk: And ethical.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Yes.
>> Matt Schrenk: I suppose.
I mean I think it's, from a
scientific perspective it would open
up all sorts of considerations
in terms of the probability
or possibility of life
on these other planets
and moons circulating and the stars.
So if it turns out to be
highly likely, probable,
then we might accelerate our efforts
to learn if there's more life
out there or certainly have a whole
different perspective on our life
on the uniqueness or importance
of our life on this planet.
But in terms of, you know, there
might also be other considerations
with our ability to
synthesize life out of nothing.
You know, what are the
ethical considerations?
A lot of these same concerns are
being met with synthetic biology
and genetic modification and
sort of deconstructing cells,
so I think we need to also consider
those perspectives in this, as well.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: And
we will in the next session.
I could just chime in very briefly
and say from a humanistic point
of view on one level it's a
wonderfully irrelevant question.
It's not going to shape the outcome
of the next election or anything
like that, but on another level
there's no more interesting
question, right?
It is the question, and so it
really would be morally profound
if we could identify what that is.
And part of what that would mean
would be coming up with a definition
of what we mean by the
origin of life, right?
And that in itself is a
very fraught question.
A lot of scientists just throw up
their hands and say never mind,
I'm just studying the chemistry, but
others say, oh, how would you know
if you found life unless
you know what life is?
And so there are important
questions of humility and our place
in the universe, our responsibility,
our stewardship of the planet,
whether we have the
ability and the right
to colonize other worlds,
things like that, so.
>> Nsikan Akpan: Yes,
and I think I approach it
from a place of just pure curiosity.
How do you have a world that
has a mouse and elephant, right?
Like how did we get everything
that's ever been created
by an organism?
How did we get Facebook?
How did we get Donald Trump?
How did we get Hillary
Clinton, right?
All of those things come
from this singular question
of how life started, so.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: And,
boy, would I like to know.
>> Nsikan Akpan: Right.
Right here?
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Actually, I
think we're going to have to ...
>> Nsikan Akpan: Okay.
Great, well, I would like to thank
Nathaniel and also to thank Matt
and it's been a really
fascinating discussion.
>> Nathaniel Comfort:
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.